john you we were circling around
the idea of socialism and communism uh
a little bit i wanted to ask you given
what you as a psychologist
know about human beings do you think
that
there's something fundamentally
incompatible with in that
world view with humanity or do you think
quote-unquote hasn't been tried properly
oh well it hasn't been tried properly
means that the world hasn't been
fortunate enough to have
me run it that's that's the constant
claim well it hasn't been tried properly
what that means is well i understand
this system deeply and if those
if if i was in charge or people like me
then it would work
it's like no it wouldn't that's that's
what would happen is you'd be wiped out
by the next
batch that were even worse than you
that's what would happen
so it's such an arrogant claim that it
hasn't been tried properly
it's so but having said that
like it's not i understand the
motivation for
uh like the desire for an egalitarian
distribution of of valuable resources
and we should walk through that
so uh it systems have a tendency
marx commented on this but it's much
deeper than marx's
uh realization systems have a tendency
to
radically distribute resources unequally
and that's really destabilizing
yep so and there's a couple of reasons
for that one reason is
um as you get more
you're offered more so i'm in a position
now where
i am offered an indefinite array of
opportunities
and i don't need them i'm not ungrateful
for it but
once you're saturated with opportunities
and your time is completely taken up
more opportunities can't be utilized and
so
and if you have money well it's way
easier to make more money i mean you can
lose it too but
it's way easier to make more money once
you've got started
and so once you are educated you have
some capital you have a connection
network
um and then let's say on in in addition
to that you're well known
you can just multiply that endlessly and
but then on the other end of things if
you have
nothing well you can't even afford to
get
started yeah so like if you start a
business
the most difficult customer to get is
the first one
once you have 10 getting a 100 is not
that hard but
getting from zero to one is virtually
impossible
and so zero is a really tough
it's a hole that's really hard to climb
out of and it's not good for society
to have a lot of people at zero
so there's this propensity for people to
fall off the end and to
degenerate down to zero and another
propensity for resources to aggregate in
the hands of very very small number of
people and it
look it doesn't matter what dimension
you measure that on so
if you look up among basketball players
you look at
successful number of points scored
there's a few people way out on the
extreme if you look at number of records
sold records produced
songs written popular songs written it's
like uh
five composers account for 95
of the classical repertoire but it's
only
5 of the music they wrote that's played
and so you see that happening in two
ways there
and the problem with that is that it
produces this radical inequality
in society and that's really
unsettling because you have a mechanism
that's very deeply embedded within you
that runs
as far as we can tell on serotonin a
fundamental brain chemical
and the the degree to which serotonin
regulates your negative emotion
is dependent on your status within the
group that you
strive for status within and what that
means is that
if you're on the bottom end of the
status hierarchy
you're much more prone to negative
emotion
and that actually hurts you physically
you're you'll die sooner you'll age
faster
you'll develop all the age-related
diseases faster it's a real
calamity psychologically and physically
and so there's endless motivation to to
to work against that tendency for
resources to be distributed so unequally
the problem is we don't know how to do
it
it's so power is such a powerful force
we don't know how to do it and
simultaneously
maintain creative and productive
endeavor for example
so because you want you want everything
to be more productive
right because you try to wipe out
absolute poverty
and maybe even give everyone you can a
certain amount of luxury
and maybe that's even better for the
planet because richer people tend to
take better care of the environment
so you want absolute wealth to rise and
you don't want inequality to
become too extreme but the systems that
have been set up to manage that
are not good at it they don't work you